so our next speaker
appeared in a Cheetos commercial when he
was eight years old
please Welcome Matt
all right great well uh I want to start
with uh Lord of the Rings people have
seen it right I'm getting a little old
so like I run into people who haven't
seen it people have seen this movie
all right has anybody not seen it
okay I think you these are recorded
talks Jerry is it okay if I tell him he
can just leave and go see it like it's
really good you should just go and it's
really great so but I'm going to ruin
something for you I apologize uh okay so
they're we're looking at two characters
here
and one of them is Frodo the supposed
hero of the story and then one of them
Sam and
um I have kind of I don't think it's
that controversial of an opinion but
even though Frodo's supposed to be the
hero of the story I actually think it
might be Sam does anybody agree with me
on that like is that that's not crazy
right like Sam is the guy okay I see
some thumbs up I see some thumbs up uh
all right so so Sam is like the sidekick
but like he's got some amazing kind of
heroic moments in the movie and there's
something analogous going on right now
with Chachi BT and embeddings okay so
everybody's talking about Chachi BT
Chachi BT is the hero of the AI story
right now
but I want to convince you that actually
embeddings are kind of like the secret
the low-key hero the like really
interesting thing
um that's that's kind of going on with
uh with openai right now uh so that's
what this talks about uh embeddings are
cooler than Chachi BT it's an
introduction to uh embeddings and uh and
how to use open ai's embedding uh
endpoint
uh quick survey who knows what
embeddings are
okay this is a decent chunk of folks all
right so I just wanted to kind of feel
the room there uh all right let's let's
do another quick survey so
um this is about Chachi BT now okay so
if you think about Chachi Pati on one of
those on one end of the spectrum you
might be underwhelmed okay yeah it's not
that cool and then the other end of the
spectrum you might be freaking out okay
you're like this is gonna take all our
jobs and you know Humanity's gonna get
wiped out I don't know you could be on
either end of the spectrum
um I've been on both ends of the
spectrum over the over the past few
months so I'm curious like who's kind of
on the underwhelm side can you just
raise your hand if you're like eh it's
not that cool got a couple hands couple
hands okay all right okay cool who's on
the like freaking outside of like things
that like okay we got all right cool
cool cool all right good good good
um we got a good mix of folks so
um all right now that we've kind of
pulled the room I'm just going to
quickly walk through kind of the agenda
for the talk so first point I'm gonna
I'm gonna try and push the people who
are freaking out a little more towards
the center all right so Chad GPT it's
cool okay but it's not that cool so
that's it's that's the asterisks right
it's like it's definitely cool but it's
not that cool we don't need to freak out
second thing embeddings are actually the
cooler thing uh I think and then how do
we actually use them all right so let's
start with why uh Chaturbate Isn't that
cool so again thinking about the
Spectrum like some of you are on the
freaking out side of things maybe like a
lot of AI influencers are over there
right they want us all to freak out a
little bit get those clicks
um maybe there's like you know Average
Joe a little bit closer to the uh the
center and then there's like there's me
right um is my clicker dead oh there it
is so so that's kind of where I am just
so you know like cards on the table okay
uh so I'm gonna I want to share a few
things that kind of pushed me from the
freaking out spot to more towards the
center of the spectrum first thing
um is a tweet from a um somebody who did
I think they were at meta they did AI
research and now they're in consultant
and they're uh they mentioned something
really interesting they called it uh
prompt drift have people heard of this
before okay okay cool cool so a couple
couple folks so they're they're you know
they're doing some Consulting they're
helping people build systems on top of
Chachi BT you know they're doing this
kind of prompt engineering type things
where they come up with these elaborate
prompts and um and they you know kind of
deploy the system and then the model
changes and then it just stops working
right it's so there's like a little bit
of a kind of a house of cards thing
going on a little bit with some of these
actual production chat gbt based systems
I mean I thought this was really
interesting and something that's kind of
under discussed
um and so when I found that I was like
okay like you know it's not like these
systems are just crushing it kind of
consistently there's some reliability
issues that the folks are worried about
so I thought that was interesting pushed
me a little more towards the center
here's another tweet this is from
somebody who has been playing around
with agents for a few months agents if
you don't know this is like going A Step
Beyond the kind of question and answer
interaction that you typically have with
chat gbt and actually like doing things
on behalf of the user so you would give
it a task like I don't know uh book me a
um a reservation you know at um at a
restaurant and it would like you know
click through some web pages to kind of
do that and so this the the important
parts of this tweet are highlighted in
red here basically this person's been
messing around with agents for about
three months
and I love this this line here they said
they're looping computer programs that
have a five to fifteen percent failure
rate every time you execute a new Loop
um so again there's like kind of
reliability issues here like you can you
can you know look at kind of the Splashy
demos that open AI or you know other
folks kind of put out but um the kind of
word on the street or the the kind of
feedback on the ground is people try to
build real systems with this is that
they're there are some reliability
issues
um this is a really interesting example
this is you might recognize this this is
an example from a New York Times article
and it's a the example is a um it's an
instance in which
gpt4 is actually worse than GPT 3.5
okay so the dominant narrative about the
iteration on these models is that we
scale them up we give them more data and
they get better kind of across the board
um but it turns out that this isn't like
always true and so I'll just quickly
walk through this example so the prompt
is Imagine an infinitely wide doorway
what is more likely to fit through it a
military tank or a car
it's a little bit of a riddle here and
gbt35 correctly you can see this
highlighted part here says that the
height and length of objects could be
potentially a limiting factor in the
doorway
um whereas gbt4 doesn't really pick up
on this Nuance uh so that's I thought
that was extremely interesting and like
a again it really challenges The
Narrative that you just make these
models bigger and they're going to be
better
so I think oh yeah one more one more
thing uh do people know about this like
Sam Altman made this comment at MIT
maybe a month or six weeks ago this like
the age of large you know giant models
is like kind of already over have people
I just raise your hand if you're if
you're familiar with this comment okay
so a couple of people okay so the again
like a big kind of piece of the
narrative around AI is this idea that
you just make the model bigger you give
it more data and it's going to be better
and here we have Sam Altman the guy
running open AI saying actually like
it's it's not that simple
um and actually what he says in this
talk is he's like he says oh I think
we'll actually make models better in
other ways besides making them bigger
and
um it turns out if you looked at the the
gpt4 leak uh like they are actually just
doing like a mixture of experts type
thing for gpt4 if you take the leak
seriously and so that um that again
challenges the idea that the path to AGI
is like really straightforward uh like
oh just we need more data and a bigger
model and more venture capital and it's
done
um so the path is actually like not
clear I think to to really get to a
version of GPT that's going to take over
our jobs okay so GPT is cool it's not
that cool we don't need to freak out why
are embeddings cooler so let's just talk
about what they are really quickly okay
really concretely it's like you you give
um a large language model some text and
then it spits out uh a list of numbers
okay or an array of numbers in the case
of open ai's embeddings it's a uh it's a
1536 length Vector okay of numbers and
what these numbers allow you to do is
essentially compare uh strings uh
according to their their meaning okay so
if you look at this this is kind of
small line apologize for this but this
you know these are words that have been
embedded in a model they're obviously
projected down from a high dimensional
space into a two-dimensional space so
that we can actually look at them and
you can see that
um words that have similar meanings
cluster together so uh things like like
eagle and deer here those things are
close together because they're animals
um ants and bees are close together
they're insects cranberries and grape
and so essentially you have this way of
kind of measuring the relatedness of
text strings it's not just words it
could be phrases sentences entire
documents now
the reason I think this is interesting
well actually let's let's delve a little
deeper though into like where these
embeddings kind of come from so if you
think about the the pieces that make up
chat gbt uh there's there's two pieces
okay and you might know this already but
there's there's kind of a just a
straight like like large language model
portion oh actually let me talk about
this
my slides might be out of order I'll
talk about this first so there's
uh I'm not gonna do that I'm sorry
so let me uh oh I I remember the order I
want to do this okay so sorry about that
so so there's two pieces let's talk
about the second piece first this this
like stands for reinforcement learning
with human feedback okay this is
um
this is something that
uh that's kind of done uh after the
large language model is trained and it's
something that allows them to tweak that
model so that it's more aligned with you
know the The Prompt that we're actually
asking
um and this actually this something as
the as the acronym suggests it it's
something that requires human feedback
like there are people that are actually
uh you know saying like this is a good
response or not a good response
um in order to kind of fine-tune these
these models a little bit make them more
aligned and this is actually a point of
failure if you think about it in in
these uh in the in like chat to BT like
systems uh because there's basically if
the prompt that somebody enters is too
different from the training data or the
data that we've received human feedback
on then it's your the model is not
really going to be able to handle it
well and this is actually I think
probably what happened with gbt like
this regression in gbt4 right is that
there's
um it just wasn't in the training data
set and so it wasn't able to handle this
uh this sort of query well uh and so
that's a point of failure in these
systems let's talk about the other part
of it and this will actually get into
where embeddings come from and we'll see
how embeddings don't suffer from the
same sort of point of failure that you
see with a chat TPT that's based on this
reinforcement learning human feedback
piece so the other part of these systems
is just the actual uh large language
model itself and the task that this this
model has
is to uh basically given a sequence of
text to predict the next token right in
in that sequence or maybe it's
predicting a a token or a word within a
uh in the middle of a of a text sequence
I'm sure we we know that already so
that's what that's what these models are
doing and you know it's a it's a it's a
it's a neural network it's a deep neural
network and so the output of this
network if you look at this last layer
here the output of the network is its
prediction of the next token right but
the layer before the output layer okay
so let me see if I can use this like
laser pointer here boom this guy right
here
so this this is the output layer okay
this is the actually doing the
prediction of the next token this layer
right here this is where embeddings come
from
okay if you this is like we we pluck
this layer out right here and this is
basically the uh the embeddings that
you're working with like open AI or any
other kind of embedding system and so
essentially what you have with
embeddings is
um it's the llm's representation of
language that is useful for predicting
the next token in a sequence okay so
when you when you're working with
embeddings you get to pluck out that
model's understanding or representation
of language and you get to skip the
finicky behavior of chat TPT that's what
I think is really interesting okay and
you can do some really powerful things
with this model's you know
representation of language and not
suffer the same sort of reliability
issues so here's one thing that you
could do so Jerry made this joke about
is anybody even using Twitter anymore
but like one what like one project you
could imagine is like oh I might want to
do sentiment analysis on people tweeting
or threading about Twitter or threads
and like understand what the overall
sentiment is about these two social
networks and so with embeddings what you
could do is you could actually embed I
don't know you could just embed the word
like this is or the phrase this is cool
or something like that right and you're
going to get you know some some Vector
that that represents that and then you
can compare that embedding to all of the
tweets or thread posts that the
embeddings of the of those tweets or
embeddings of those thread posts and see
like oh is it closer to like this is
cool or this is lame when you when you
kind of compare those embeddings you can
do like like a distance measurement like
a cosine similarity or something like
that and so what you essentially have
here is like a zero shot classification
system where you don't need to
necessarily train any new data for this
specific task you can just use the
embeddings to actually do sentiment
analysis which I think is really cool
another example of this that's kind of
similar is um product recommendations so
imagine you know you take a bunch of
descriptions of content on Netflix you
embed those descriptions and
um and then you you know those
descriptions might be for uh films or
shows that a particular user is watching
and so if if they have kind of
consistent preferences the embeddings of
those descriptions are going to Cluster
in the kind of high dimensional
embedding space and then you can
recommend if you if you embed kind of
the entire library of Netflix you can
recommend similar shows or content that
is close to the that cluster in the high
dimensional embedding space and again
you can just do this like kind of
trivially just piggybacking off of the
large language models representation of
language so I think that's another
really cool application and then another
one you know I have to bring this up
because we're you know at an R
conference but um you let's say you're
you know you're working on an R project
and you want to find a particular usage
of a function okay I'm sure you've run
into this before where you search for
the function and you like can't quite
remember the name of the function that's
being used like you like miss one word
or something like that so maybe you're
looking for like you know uh bind calls
um you know the like tidy R stuff and
you accidentally type in like bind
columns or like attach columns or
something like that when you're
searching so with a standard search
system you're kind of out of luck right
like you're just gonna turn up empty but
again with embeddings uh let's say you
embed all of the function declarations
within a code base and then you also
embed the user's query for the function
that they're searching for then you can
actually start to search for things
based on the meaning of the words
involved and so even if you don't
exactly get the function name correct
you're still going to be able to surface
similar function names that are close in
the embedding space or have a similar
meaning
um and that I think is really cool so
let's let's actually talk about oh we
only have four minutes talk about how to
use these things so uh using embeddings
with open AIS it's not that hard so uh
you can install open AI package and then
there's a create embedding function that
you can use it you give it a there's a
specific embedding model that you can
specify at a zero two is the one that's
recommended and then you can just give
it phrases or words or documents and it
will embed these things so it's not too
difficult to create them again you're
going to get this you know 15
um it's it's like an HTTP response and
inside of that is this um you know 1536
length vector and then from there it's
actually not that hard to project uh
these high you know kind of high
dimensional vectors into a
two-dimensional space and plot them so
you can kind of see the relationship
between the text the text embeddings
that you've um that you've um you know
asked open AI to embed for you so this
is just a few lines for how to do this
I'm not going to walk through this line
by line because we're a little short on
time but basically if you you know if
you have code like this you can get a
nice ggplot
um and you can see here like the terms
that I embedded were like dog and cat
banana apple and democracy like the dog
and cat kind of cluster together banana
and apple quest to go cluster to go
democracy is like far away right it's
like a different these are different
concepts
um so that that's that's kind of a neat
thing and then this I actually do want
to spend a little bit of time on so if
you wanted to implement this kind of
semantic search uh thing that this
example of semantic code search it's
again like surprisingly easy to do you
can do it in a few lines so first you're
creating the embedding okay we've
already seen this like a line like this
before you have to grab the actual
embedding Vector itself from the HTTP
response that's all that's happening
here and then um suppose you have like
uh use it like a string here this is the
user input so we're basically just
embedding that here in these first few
lines and then let's say you have a you
know a table of embeddings of like terms
and the actual
um you know embedding vectors associated
with that in like a list column and a
table then what you can do is you can
mutate in the cosine similarity of these
things
um and and so you compute that as a
column and then you can just arrange by
this and so here what you have is you
can rank
your all the terms that you've embedded
by their similarity to a particular
input that that's been passed into the
function and so it's really neat how
just in a few lines of code you could
actually start to implement like
semantic code search or um you know even
like thinking about things like product
recommendation that's it's a it's a kind
of semantic search right um so kind of
riffing on this you can you can get
pretty far uh okay so we've talked about
you know semantic search over functions
and code obviously like another
application of this is semantic search
over documents
um and so again like you maybe you don't
have to use the actual terms that appear
in the documents just terms that have
similar meaning and surface the correct
documents based on that but I want to
quickly share I have one minute left
like how I'm using embeddings to do
semantic search over application States
what does that even mean
um so the application for this is
basically let's say you don't know how
to do something in a piece of software
I'd say the software is amplitude Okay
so let's say you're using amplitude you
don't know how to do something
the idea here is you can type what you
want to do so in this case it's like
create a graph that shows account of
sessions over time but it could also be
how do I add a user in amplitude you hit
enter and then you're going to get these
like in-app step-by-step directions on
how to accomplish that task within the
application
and we're using embeddings to do this it
turns out that if you embed the
application copy associated with a
particular page or application state
that application copy or text is a
pretty good indication of what's
possible on that page and so you can
kind of match up a user's query of what
they want to do with the right page that
they need to be on to do that and guide
the user into the right place so that's
something that that we're kind of using
embeddings for right now and I have
seven seconds left so it looks like I'm
going to finish right on time